il est bien 20h12 merci de nous avoir
attendu le football à déranger nos
habitudes le football et le fait que
l'émission de guy lux étaient
enregistrés nous n'avons pas voulu la
coupe et à la clé les footballeurs
français et soviétiques ont joué les
prolongations jusqu'au penalty à moscou
la france a perdu mais les amateurs de
football savent déjà cela ils l'ont
suivi sur l'antenne sur antenne 2
jusqu'à 19h40 un match valeureux pour le
tricolore
mais qu'une fin peu heureuse dans ce
journal d'ici 20h30 le compte rendu de
deux élections portugal et vietnam
la semaine à venir en france il n'y aura
pas de sport vous aurez dans le dernier
journal de la moto et du rugby
ici tout juste l'arrivée du tiercé est
un peu de cinéma les élections d'abord
celle du portugal deux cent soixante
trois députés à élire et une possibilité
de nouveau départ pour la démocratie
portugaise après deux années difficiles
la révolution portugaise adopte le style
américain au moins pour les badges en
voici quatre représentants les quatre
grands qui domine ces élections
portugaises parti communiste parti
socialiste centriste du ppd et cds le
parti conservateur de droite il ya un an
aux élections à l'assemblée constituante
les communistes avaient obtenu 12 et
demi pour cent des voix les socialistes
38 les centristes 26 et le parti
conservateur cds cet ennemi % malgré
l'absence de sondages pendant la
campagne électorale
on tient pour certain que ce parti
conservateur va doubler et même tripler
ses voies passant de 7 à 15 ou 20%
alors une question pourquoi cette
remontée de la droite au portugal
deux ans seulement après la chute de la
dictature de salazar
le cds n'assumer aucune responsabilité
gouvernementale depuis la révolution des
oeillets en avril 74
les électeurs ne peuvent pas lui
demander de comptes il accueille donc
tous les mécontents et ils sont nombreux
la crise économique est aiguë
l'industrie tourne au ralenti la réforme
agraire est combattu par les grands
moyens propriétaire il y a cinq cent
mille chômeurs pour 3 millions de
travailleurs et l'inflation tourne
autour de 20 % par an circonstance
aggravante
près d'un million de pieds noirs
portugais ont quitté précipitamment le
mozambique et l'angola
la mère patrie fait le maximum pour les
secourir près de 100000 sont ainsi
hébergées dans tous les hôtels du pays
mais ses pieds noirs se considèrent
comme les victimes d'une décolonisation
bâclée et ont tendance à accuser les
dirigeants actuels
de plus le parti cds a fait une campagne
très démagogiques en direction des
réfugiés d'afrique
si la droite progresse donc qui va
perdre des voix
logiquement les socialistes et le centre
selon quel pourcentage réponse serait
vouloir lire dans le marc de café
disons qu'il est probable que le parti
socialiste sera encore en tête ce soir
dans une large mesure il restera
larbitre pour la formation du prochain
gouvernement
mario soares le leader socialiste a
d'ailleurs déjà prévenu le ps gouvernera
seul ou restera dans l'opposition
officiellement tout au moins il ne veut
entendre parler ni d'alliance avec les
communistes ni de rapprochement avec la
droite
on notera mais c'est très localisées
peut-être assez peu significatif
on notera que les résultats compte tenu
du décalage horaire sont déjà connus
pour macao dernier territoire portugais
d'outre-mer à la pointe sud de la chine
c'est le cd est on nous parlait
précisément à bouchard l'instant c'est
la droite modérée qui arrive très
largement en tête 16 cents voix et le
parti communiste très largement que 26
voix sur plus de 2000 exprimer la
proximité de la grande chine de pékin ne
profite pas aux pc de macarou scrutin
sans surprise l'autre élection qui est
une sorte de cérémonie
l'élection des députés du nouveau
vietnam ou pour être candidat il fallait
être favorable à la réunification
on peut dire que pour le sud et le nord
ensemble c'est un tournant mais il est
déjà pris et la route est en sens unique
dimanche 25 avril
de la frontière chinoise à la pointe de
cam à eau dans le vietnam tout entier
une or à l'extrême sud
la réunification va être symbolisé par
les élections générales
rien que pour ça ils vont aujourd'hui ho
chi minh ville
le dernier recensement indique un
million sept cent mille électeurs de
plus de 18 ans selon les autorités
révolutionnaire 90% des anciens soldats
de l'armée de thiou aurait après leur
passage dans les centres de rééducation
retrouver leurs droits civiques
seuls les anciens officiers sont encore
en période probatoire et pour la plupart
toujours dans les camps de reconversion
afin de mobiliser les vietnamiens pour
cette cérémonie électoral et aussi pour
préparer l'ensemble de la population
depuis plusieurs mois une grande
campagne de lutte pour l'alphabétisation
a été entreprise dans tout le pays
en effet dans certains secteurs du sud
vietnam
il fallait compter plus de 30 %
d'électeurs ne sachant pas lire
aujourd'hui un rattrapage intensif par
des cours du soir aurait donné des
résultats satisfaisants de véritable
répétition ont été organisés dans toutes
les circonscriptions dans les 1500
bureaux électoraux de saigon la
population a été invitée à suivre tout
le processus du vote
une fois pour rien seulement pour
apprendre
chez nous la semaine qui s'annonce
comprend le lot habituel d'interrogation
le mouvement étudiant trois mois déjà
qu'il est déclenché la grève continue
dans de nombreuses universités
établissements mais les examens
approchent et s'il est sûr que la grève
peut durer jusqu'au 1er mai il est
probable que la protestation après devra
prendre d'autres formes
à moins que la troisième coordination
nationale des étudiants qui doit se
tenir mardi à paris en décide autrement
aujourd'hui à amiens c'était les
universitaires en lutte contre la
réforme qui se réunissait pour prolonger
leurs actions dans le secteur social les
centrales syndicales concentrent leurs
efforts sur la préparation du 1er mai
les manifestations de samedi
coïncideront avec le 40e anniversaire
des luttes ouvrières de 1936 mais pour
la cgt et la cfdt quelques divergences
rendent moins efficace qu'il ya quelques
mois
l'unité d'action voulue par leurs
dirigeants alors que la cgt vient de
chiffrer à 1 million deux cent
quatre-vingt dix mille le nombre de
chômeurs en france on s'interroge par
ailleurs de nouveau sur l'avenir de l'ip
le tribunal de commerce de paris doit
dire au milieu de la semaine quelle
solution de liquidation il envisage
après une ultime rencontre entre le
syndic et les actionnaires pour une
dernière possibilité de sauvetage
judiciaire la commission qui décidera de
l'éventuelle révision du procès de
roland agret doit se réunir demain à
paris
la dernière déclaration du détenu
santelli tendant à innocenter agréé a
conduit le garde des sceaux à faire
procéder à une nouvelle audition
d'antoine santé nih c'est la dernière
pièce versée au dossier de la commission
de révision
amiens demain un autre exemple de
justice difficile pierre goldman rejugé
le 19 décembre 69 un inconnu à bas coût
des vols vers deux pharmaciennes dans
leurs officines du boulevard richard
lenoir à paris
il est vu par plusieurs personnes et en
particulier par un jeune agent de police
qui tente de maîtriser le meurtrier et
qui reçoit une balle dans le ventre
plusieurs mois plus tard pierre goldman
est arrêté et est arrêté sur
dénonciation d'un homme qualifié d'
informateur par la police personne n'a
jamais prononcé son nom personne ne l'a
jamais entendu officiellement mais pire
goldman dit le connaître sans jamais
vouloir non plus révéler son identité
voilà le cadre général de ce second
procès c'est dans le détail que se
profilent
doute ce doute qui a troublé le premier
procès et qui a suscité tant de
manifestations et de prises de positions
de toutes sortes depuis le verdict de la
cour d'assises de paris le 13 décembre
74 réclusion criminelle à perpétuité
doute aussi j'en suis personnellement
convaincu qui a motivé sur le fond l'art
et d'annulation de la cour de cassation
et le renvoi devant les assises d'amiens
devant goldman aucune preuve matérielle
autour de lui un faisceau de
présomptions chacune d'elles ne tirant
sa valeur que de la présence des autres
en vérité les juges damien les jurés
damien vont avoir à juger plusieurs
procès d'abord celui d'un dossier où les
seuls éléments concrets sont donc des
témoignages humains
ensuite celui d'un homme qui coupable ou
non n'est de toute façon plus le même
qu'en 1969
le goldman de 76 c'est mûri en prison
s'est transformé en un être qui ne se
reconnaît plus dans ses actes passés ce
qui n'efface pas d'ailleurs le souvenir
des deux femmes a battu le procès aussi
des témoins dont les souvenirs sont
maintenant mélangé à ce qu'ils croient
être leur souvenir le procès encore des
jurés de paris dont toute une opinion a
hurlé qu'il s'était trompé
le procès enfin d'un appareil judiciaire
qui a reconnu lui même qu'il fallait
recommencer le doute la mémoire effacée
la bonne volonté et les autres plus les
passions ça ne va pas être facile à
amiens cette semaine de rendre justice
réaction difficile à prévoir
celle des militants corses qui ont
appris ce matin la date à laquelle le
docteur edmond simeoni et quatre autres
autonomistes seront jugés par la cour de
sûreté de l'état
le 17 mai prochain c'est à dire huit
mois et demi après l'action de commando
d'une cinquantaine d'hommes à aléria sur
la côte orientale de la corse dans des
journées qu'elle était trop chaude et
qui se solda par un mort et 18 blessés à
la suite de heurts avec les crs
le tiercé du jour
nous allons en suivant l'arrivée tél
vous avez pu la voir cet après midi le
prix du bel air servait de support aux
paris couplé gagnant et au tiercé
aujourd'hui à longchamp c'est un
handicap avec 19 partant au sein d'une
grande journée classique à longchamp
avec de belles courses
le troisième cheval arrivée a été
distancé par les commissaires et c'est
donc le 13 chars père suivies d'une
croix mist foule edukators spim qui ont
inscrit leur nom au palmarès pour
rapporter dans l'ordre en 1330 francs
pour safran jouer et dans l'ordre
différents vous lisez sur cet écran 666
france est un petit rapport pour
handicap avec 19 partants le cinéma
aucun film de marco ferreri ne laisse
indifférent
souvenez vous de la grande bouffe voilà
du nouveau et encore un parfum de
scandale france au chalet le moins qu'on
puisse dire est que cela n'est pas très
agréable à regarder
entre autres délicatesses en effet la
dernière femme nous montre un monsieur
qui se trouve dans une position
nettement inconfortable avec une scie
électrique il découpe comme un vulgaire
saucisson une partie de son anatomie sur
laquelle je ne m'étendrai pas ayant
oublié à la maison mots stop de feuilles
de vigne
disons simplement qu ainsi a tranché
dans le vif du sujet ce que l'on
pourrait appeler le noeud de l'action
elle donc après celui de la grande
bouffe un nouveau scandale signé marco
ferreri
on le croit volontiers mais de tous
côtés des esprits brillants et distingué
nous assure le contraire
ces protections raison que notre victime
de la civilisation du gadget aurait pris
le parti de se raccourcir monsieur
ferrer il lui est un observateur lucide
passionnés des normes contemporaines
un philosophe et ça l'a amené à dresser
un constat de faillite
la faillite d'un sommes en face d'une
nouvelle génération de femmes qui
refusent de prendre son ancien maître
son ancien tyran pour le roi des animaux
soit moi je veux bien tout ce que l'on
veut y compris admettre que l'ambition
de monsieur ferreri se situe malgré les
apparences au dessus de la ceinture de
son triste héros malheureusement je ne
vois dans la dernière femme que deux
acteurs très bon qui se trouvent la
plupart du temps dans des postures
ridicule voire affligeantes
gérard depardieu 100 % à l'état naturel
le ventre constat montana
van est signée avec le ventre et ornella
mutti à un tableau de rafael sur lequel
un gardien de musée syndic aurait permis
au public de laisser traîner des traces
de doigts sales que monsieur ferry me
pardonne ce pourquoi est ce que je dis
c'est me pardonnerai jamais mais sont
absents naturisme nous rappellent
irrésistiblement le naturalisme de feu
antoine celui du théâtre libre aux
alentours de 1900 à cette époque on
croyait pour donner l'illusion de la vie
qu'il suffisait de mettre de vrais
poulet dans les assiettes des acteurs
aujourd'hui les sexes ont remplacé les
poulets ne vont pas quitter pour cela le
règne du carton pâte
c'est dommage c'est dommage parce que
malgré tout l'idée de monsieur ferry sa
thèse était digne d'intérêt
le couple ces problèmes c'est révision
son avenir c'est passionnant déjà adam
eve ne parlait que de ça seulement voilà
il me semble que monsieur ferry a perdu
de vue un détail qui a quand même son
importance cette petite fugue pour flûte
et triangle que l'homme et la femme se
joue depuis l'origine des temps
s'accommode mal d'une partition
supplémentaire pour grosse caisse et tam
tam comment pourrais-je sans passer pour
un dangereux rétrograde faire maintenant
les leurs de jean gabin jean gabin un
acteur comme on n'en fait plus comme
parent et il faut plus en faire et dans
toute la loi on le sait consistent avant
donner un second visage à jean renoir à
jacques becker à marcel carné à tant
d'autres
il est pourtant est un an jean gabin
dans l'année sainte de jean girault
entouré de toujours remarquable jean
claude brialy et de danielle darrieux
belle comme aux plus beaux jours
étonnant en faux évêque sérieux comme un
pape qui s'est ficherait perdu demandé
ce courage et perfide peut dire de lui
alors monseigneur gaba soyez bénis au
niçois les dieux du temps ils ont ramené
l'hiver sur la france depuis hier et
demain les températures seront encore
plus basses qu'aujourd'hui dans l'est et
le nord du pays
plus douce tout de même sur la manche la
bretagne à la gironde mais stationnaire
ailleurs le temps restera nuageux avec
des éclaircies et de la neige en
montagne il y aura des orages sur le sud
des alpes et la corse
vers 23h30 le dernier journal avec
gérard aux
l'équipe du week-end vous dit à samedi
prochain et dimanche aussi est bonne ce
soir